their unique little species they live in
wetlands primarily which is not what you
typically think of when you think of
rattlesnakes the real stronghold for
Eastern massasauga is here in Michigan
this species was recently listed under
the u.s. Endangered Species Act as as
federally threatened and that protects
them from a lot of the activities that
are affecting them but it doesn't
protect them from something like sneak
fungal disease so snake fungal disease
is an emerging fungal pathogen it's
found to infect about 30 some-odd
species of snakes in the United States a
lot of these snake species particularly
massasauga rattlesnake SAR already
suffering from the effects of multiple
stressors so habitat loss these things
were persecuted at one point directly
snake fungal disease we know is
relatively new to these populations and
it's just an additional stressor on top
of the things that these snakes are
already experiencing even if this
disease occurs at a relatively low
prevalence maybe five to ten percent
that could be an additional five to ten
percent of mortality that's added on top
of what's already occurring those are
the kinds of things that can drive these
populations to extinction it seems to be
an increasing phenomenon that emerging
infectious diseases have been impacting
wildlife species across different taxes
such as bat white nose syndrome and
phibian Kitteridge fungus and now also
snake fungal disease these pathogens are
so complex and much more complicated
than we first assumed we still have so
many questions that are been unanswered
even though some of these species are
common because we don't have a long-term
dataset before there was ever a reason
to be concerned it makes it very
difficult for us to predict what will
happen in the future
so not rattling yep touching once so for
the last seven or so years we have been
collecting mark-recapture data on this
population of Eastern massasauga
rattlesnake the idea is to establish a
population that we can study over the
long term so we can try and understand
the changes in demography and the
population dynamics we are lucky enough
here to have been studying this
population before we detected the
disease which will allow us to
understand the impact to the population
over time we can lose individuals right
and we know that we lose individuals
occasionally but from a conservation
standpoint it's really important to
understand what's the impact of
populations what we really need to do is
to sample in the environment figure out
where it's distributed and then try and
understand how it's spreading both
locally and across the country
ultimately hopefully not across the
globe hopefully we can apply some of
what we learned then slow or control the
spread before declines and snakes really
become a common place to be able to
respond more quickly is of the essence
and right now we have an advantage with
snake holding disease I really hope to
get more people aware that we have
rattlesnakes in Michigan and that they
are important they provide a valuable
ecosystem service control mammal
populations and mammals carry ticks you
know they deserve to be here they
provide a service and they're just a
beautiful species
[Music]
[Music]